قال رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان ان خروجه
من مقر القياده العامه في الخرطوم لم يتم
بموجب اي صفقه واكد من قاعده عسكريه شمالي
بورسودان رفضه التوافق مع من سماهم
المتمردين ومن جانبه طلب قائد قوات الدعم
السريع بربط اي مفاوضات للتسويه بالبحث عن
حل سياسي شامل وتاسيس جيش جديد موحد
وتصفيه الوجود السياسي والحزبي بمؤسسات
الدوله وفق
[موسيقى]
قوله اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا لنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ماده وافع زياره
البرهان الى بوتسودان في ظل استمرار
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الخرطوم ومدن اخرى وما دلاله تاكيده رافضه
الاتفاق مع من سماهم الخونه والمتمردين
وكيف نقرا تزامنا هذه التطورات والمواقف
مع دعوه حماتي ربط مفاوضات التسويه بالبحث
عن حل سياسي واقرار جيش جديد وتصفيه
الوجود السياسي والحزبي في مؤسسات الدوله
وكذلك ما المسارات المحتمله للازمه
السودانيه في ظل انغلاق سبل الحوار
وانسداد الافق السياسي واستمرار القتال
بين الجانبين وتردي الاوضاع الانسانيه في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
في اول حديث يدلي به بعد خروجه من مقر
القياده العامه للجيش في الخرطوم حيث امضى
130 يوما كشف قائد الجيش ورئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان عن ان عمليه خروجه من مقر قياده
الجيش كانت بترتيب من القوات المسلحه
وانها لم تكن في اطار اي صفقه كما نفى
البرهان اثناء حديثه في قاعده بحريه
سودانيه شمالي بورسودان ايانيه للاتفاق مع
من سماهم الخونه والمتامرين وكان البرهان
وصل الى بورسودان عصر الاحد قادما من
عطبره شماليه البلاد والتي وصلها نهار
مغادرته مقر القياده العامه للجيش بعد 130
يوما من اندلاع الحرب بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
كل وحداتنا في كل مكان واقفه وقفه واحده
عشان تهزم هذا التمرد عشان تهزم هذه
الخيانه عشان تحزن هؤلاء
المرتزقه القادمين مختلف الدنيا نحن طبعا
واقفين بنقاتل كجيش وكسودان برانا ما
معانا اي ظهير ونحن بنعتز بالكلام ده احنا
بنقاتل برانه كجيش
سودانيين نحن معتمدين على رقبتنا وهنعتمد
على رقبتنا وعلى الله
[موسيقى]
في مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الدوحه هنا عادل الباز الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني وعبر الهاتف من ابو جاء
الدكتور كامل اهلا بكما في ما وراء الخبر
السؤال لك سيد عادل الباز ما الذي جعل
البرهان وهو قائد الجيش
يغادر مقر موقع المعركه في الخرطوم بهذه
السرعه
اعتقد ان في ذلك اشاره المهمه جدا الا ان
الاوضاع في السودان وفي الخرطوم هي تحت
سيطره القوات المسلحه والصيد الرئيس اطمان
على ان الخطه التي وضعت جنرالات الجيش
تمضي في الاتجاه الذي خطه لها ولا خوف من
اي
انتكاسات
يمكن ان تحدث الان لان
الجميع متفق على انهاء هذا التمرد بالطرق
التي وضعت وبالتخطيط الذي شعره مهمه اشاره
اخرى
هنالك قضايا عالغه وملفات عالغه ينبغي ان
يتعامل مع السيد الرئيس ولا يستطيع احد
غيره ان يتعامل معه مثلا الحكومه
السودانيه
متعطله لفتره الطويله جدا وتنتظر يعني
يعني رصيد الرئيسي ان يغرر في شانها يمكن
السيد نائب الرئيس
قبل كده انوه لانه ضروره تكوين حكومه
للتعامل مع الواقع الصعب في السودان هي
القتال يجري في منطقه يمكن محدده 23 الف
كيلو متر هي مساحه الخرطوم هذا هو هذا هو
الموقع اسعب للغتار اما باقي السودان
امن ولكنه يعاني من عدم وجود حكومه تدير
شؤونه وتتعامل مع التحديات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه والانسانيه ولذلك هذا ملف
تكوين حكومه غادره على التعامل مع هذه
التحديات كان واحد من الملفات العالقه
بيحتاج السيد الرئيس نتعامل معها وكذلك
يتعامل مع الخارج لانك متعلمين انه هنالك
كثير من المبادرات من الايجاد من الدول
الدول نريد ان نفهم هذه عمليه الخروج هذه
والطريقه التي تمت بها وحرص البرهان على
القول انها لم تكن في اطار
وانها بترتيب من الجيش نفسه ما دلاله
الحرص على تاكيد على هذه النقطه ما
الرساله التي يريد ان يرسلها اشاعات كثيره
رايت في الوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان هذا
الخروج تم باتفاق مع المتمردين وان هذا
الخروج تم بواسطه الطائره امريكيه وان هذا
الخروج اشتركت فيه جهات اقليميه وخرج
باتفاق وما الى ذلك ولذلك هذه الاشاعات
تكاثفت
واراد السيد الرئيس ان يرد على هذه
الاشاعات مؤكدا ان ان خروجه من
الموقع الذي كان فيه في القياده العامه تم
بعمليه عسكريه تم بعمليه عسكريه سوداء
وتخطيط سوداني
وتنفيذ سوداني ولم تشترك اي جهه خارجيه في
هذه وكان ذلك رساله مهمه
لتحضن كل الاغاني
كثيره اريد فقط ان ارحب ايضا بضيفنا الذي
ينضم الينا عبر الانترنت من الخرطوم
الباشا بيج عضو المجلس الاستشاري لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع اهلا وسهلا بك السيد
الباشا الطبيب تحدث السيد عادل باز عن
تكهنات وعن شائعات في وسائل التواصل وايضا
من ضمنها كان هناك ربما مراج ان البرهان
بالطريقه التي خرج بها ربما يبحث عن
الصفقه او عن عمليه تفاوضيه
يسير في اطارها الان بعد التصريحات التي
ادلى بها في بورسودان والتي نافى فيها اي
امكانيه لذلك ووصف الطرف الاخر
بالمتمردين والخونه كيف تلقى الدعم السريع
هذه
التصريحات
مرحبا بكم استاذي الكريم والتحيه لك
والتحيه لمشاهدي قناه الجزيره والتحيه لكل
ابناء الشعب السوداني في ربوع وطن الحبيب
استاذي الكريم
تصريحات البرهان اليوم هي كانت تصريحات
صادمه لكل الشعب السوداني وكان الكثير من
ابناء الشعب السوداني يريدون لهذه الحرب
ان تقيف وبالامس القريب اصدر السيد قائد
قوات الدعم السريع رؤيا للحل السياسي في
السودان ولانهاء هذه الحرب لكن يبدو الان
ان البرهان هو ي
ريد الضغط من جهات سياسيه محددا علمها
تماما وهذه يعني يعني الاراده الذي يعني
يريدها يعني البرهان هي لزياده معاناه
الشعب السوداني
لمزيد من التدمير الذي تشهده البنيه
التحتيه للسودان الان وحقيقه نحن في الدعم
السريع هذه تصريحات التصريحات الذي قتلى
بها الب
رهان يعني تعنينا بشيء اذا اراد الحرب
فنحن الان موجودون في الميدان وجنودنا
الان موجودون في الميدان ومحققين انتصارات
كبيره جدا
يعني
في كل
ينتظرون على جيش البرهان
بخصوص التصريحات نفسها
كيف قراتها انت سيد هاتسن هل ترى انها
فعلا تغلق الباب على اي
جهود تفاوضيه محاولات يمكن ان تنجح لانهاء
الحرب ووقفه
هذا ليس تصريحا جديا من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع اعتقد ان هذا ايضا محاوله من
البرهان لكي يظهر انه هو المسيطر وانه في
موقف قوي
نسبيا يحاول ان يبني الدعم الدولي
لمساعدته في انهاء الحرب اذن واضح انه
يستخدم موقعه خارج البلاد الان من اجل ان
يجد سبلا لانهاء هذه الحرب
والجنرال حماتي يحاول ان يبقى مؤثرا يحاول
ان يقول انه لا يزال يتوجه الى الاسره
الدوليه لكننا جميعا نرى ما يحصل هنا
اذن فقط يعني لنضع هذه التصريحات للبرهان
اليوم في سياقها لانها تاتي ايضا غداه نشر
قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
معروف باحمدتي ما سماها رؤيه الدعم السريع
من اجل بناء دوله سودانيه على اسس جديده
الرؤيه تضمنت اشتراط حمادتي ان تقوم اي
مفاوضات تهدف للتسويه على ما سماه البحث
عن حل سياسي شامل كما حدد مواصفات محدده
للدوله قال ان اي مفاوضات قادمه يجب ان
تتضمنها من بينها اعتماد نظام حكم فدرالي
وحكومه مدنيه تمثل كل اقاليم السودان كما
اشترط احمدتي ما سماه اقرار تاسيس جيش
سوداني جديد بغرض بناء مؤسسه عسكريه واحده
تنائى بنفسها عن السياسه كما دعا قائد
قوات الدعم السريع الى ما سماها تصفيه
الوجود السياسي والحزبي داخل مؤسسات
الدوله
المدنيه والعسكريه سيد عادل الباز ليست
هذه نقاط جوهريه في اي رؤيه لبناء دوله
حديثه
صحيح اذا كانت جاده وليس
شعاراتيه موجود في السلطه ولا بنسمع له اي
شعارات ولا اي مطالب ولا اي اي نقطه من
النقاط التي ذكرها كان يناضل من اجلها بل
كان يتامر على الثوره وهو الذي انغلب
عليها في من قبل
وكل هذه النظريات الان لا تجدي لانه الان
هنالك حرب تجري على الارض هذه
الحرب ينبغي ان تحسم بطريقه محدده تنتهي
من هذه من هذا التمر ثم بعد ذلك
نذهب الى الرؤيه نذهب الى تفاوض نذهب الى
غرض سياسي ولان الحديث الان عن رؤيا في ظل
الاوضاع المتدهوره للتمرد ثم اللجوء الى
يعني يعني الرؤيه تصدر عن شخص كان شريك
البرهان اليس من حقه
ان ينتقل الى رؤيه سياسيه اخرى
هذه الرؤيه السياسيه ينتقل لها متى حين
تتضع قواته وتنهزم
يلجا الى شعارات سياسيه وليس الرؤيه لها
لها عمق ولا لها
جذور في في فكره الحركه ولا عند الا في
ادوات الحركه لم تتحدث ابدا عن نظام
فيدرالي ولم تتحدث عن جيش موحد وهي كانت
ضمن هذه المنظومه وكانت تحبس بامن الدوله
هي نفسها وتقاتل من ضمن قوات النظام
السابق في دارفور فهذه رؤيه تصدر الان مما
ينصف اي مصداقيه لها وفي وقت هذه القوات
تتدهور وتهزم
وليس لها اي وضع
ان تعيد موضعها في ساحه
اعتذر عن مقاطعه يعني في النهايه ايضا اذا
اردنا ان نكون موضعين الا تتعارض هذه
الرؤيه مع يعني بنود معينه كان حماتي اصلا
يعني
تعهد بها في السابق بانه سينائى عن
العمليه السياسيه ويتركها للمدنيين
يا استاذي الكريمه السيده الفارغه محمد
حمدان هو الشريك الرئيسي فيما يسمى بمجلس
السياده الذي يتزعمه البرهان الان لذلك هو
جزء لا يتجزا من بناء الدوله السودانيه
وله الحق في اصدار هذه الرؤيه السياسيه
للحل السياسي الشامل في السودان لذلك صدرت
هذه الرؤيه وهي يعني اراده حقيقيه وهو له
اراده حقيقيه
الدلاله المعينه هو يعني دوما يسعى الى
ايقاف هذه الحرب من اجل بناء دوله سودانيه
فيها
يعني فيها العداله والمساواه وفيها يعني
اشراك حقيقي لكل الاقاليم السودانيه ولكل
المحمشين يعني يعني بالسودان لذلك هو يعني
بادر باظهار هذه هذه الرؤيه ليقطع الطريق
امام الذين يدعون الى الى هذه الحرب
والذين يريدون اشعال هذه الحرب ويصبون
الزيد على النار لمزيد من اجعل هذه الحرب
والذين يتحدثون الان عن هزيمه الدعم
السريع هذه احلام لا تتحقق لهم الدعم
السريع الان منتظر في كل الجبهات القتال
ومن يقول ان الدعم السريع يقاتل فقط في
الخرطوم 25 الف كيلو متر هذا كذب الدعم
السريع العام موجود في ولايه شمال كردفان
وبلاد جنوب كردفان وولايات دارفور الخمس
وولايه الجزيره والدعم السريعه الان يعني
بيده ممكن ان يصل البرهان في يعني في يعني
ولايه البحر الاحمر في بورسودان الدعم
السريع يده طوله ممكن يعني
هذه النقطه ما تعليقك على الرؤيه التي
طرحها احمدتي هنا
وايضا
الاشتراطات التي وضعها من اجل
الشكل الذي يجب ان تكون عليه الدوله
تحليلا اعيد تدويره وسبق للجميع من قبل
خلال 20 العام الذي مره ان تناقله ليس فيه
اي جديد ليس فيه اي استثنائي وليس فيه اي
تفصيل
انها لغه جميله نعم واعتقد انه كان يحسب
انها سوف
تحظى باعجاب واستحسان الاسره الدوليه ولكن
دعونا لا ننسى انه في الوقت نفسه الذي
يصدر هذه الرؤيه يغتصب النساء يدمر كره
والبلدات ويعذب الناس ويقتلهم هو ليس شخصا
يمكن ان نصدقه ليس شخصا في موقع يجعل منه
قادرا على ان يحاضر بالسودان او الاسره
الدوليه حينما الديمقراطيه والحوكمه
والسلام هناك نقطه ربما السيد باشا ساعدنا
ان نفهمها فيما يتعلق بما سماه
بالجيش الجديد ما المقصود هل يمكن ان
يتوقع ان يقبل الجيش ان ينخرط كعنصر في
هذا الجيش الجديد
يا استاذي الكريم الجيش الجديد الذي يقصده
السيد القائد هو اصلاح المؤسسه العسكريه
المؤسسه العسكريه التي يعني تاسست منذ
الاستعمار يعني سيطرت عليها نخبه سياسيه
محدده ومن جهات محدده وشعب السوداني يريد
ان يرى نفسه في هذه المؤسسه العسكريه
وكل الشعب الالي يتطلع ان تكون
عمليه الدمج التي كان وافق عليها في
السابق
يعني واحده من شروط الدمج هي اصلاح
المؤسسه العسكريه واصلاح يعني يعني تتم
مراجعه كل كل يعني المعاهد العسكريه بما
فيها الكليه الحربيه واحده من الشروط
الاساسيه لدمج قوات الدعم السريع
القوات المسلحه هي كانت الاصلاح
وهذا ما رفضه البرهان ورفضه
الجيش يعني في السودان يريدون ان تبقى هذه
المؤسسه بهذه التركيبه ليقضوا على
الديمقراطيه وعلى اي حكومه يعني يعني
هل فعلا تجاوزنا مساله الدمج هنا
لا انا اعتقد اننا تخطيناها انا لا اعتقد
ان قوه الدعم السريع اصلا تنوي ان تندمج
في الجيش وطبعا ليس هناك امكانيه في
المستقبل ان نرى هذه القوه تندمج في الجيش
بعد ان ارتكبت هذه الفضاء وصفكت الدماء
بين هذين الجيشين اذا فكره الاندماج في
جيش واحد وطنيا موحد هي
بس تحصل كيف ترى المستقبل بالنسبه له
حين يفوز احد الطرفين لن يكون هناك
تسويه بالتفاوض ولا حل سياسي بين القوتين
سيكون هناك خاسر ورابح وهذه الطريقه
الوحيده ليوقفوا القتال اذا اعد الباز
تحدث عن الوضع الانساني
كارثي والذي يتحدث عنه اطراف دوليه كثيره
برايك انت ومن وجهه نظرك
كل المعطيات الان على الساحه السودانيه
كيف ترى المخرج
الغريب في هذا الامر الذين يعني تسببوا في
الحرب وتسبهم في القتال وتسبب في تشريد
الناس وتسبب في الواقع الانساني يتحدثون
على الديمقراطيه والاصلاح والرؤيه انا
استغرب من هذه المليشه المتمرده التي
تختصب كما قال الان وتقتل الناس وتتحدث عن
مسائل فكريه وسياسيه
يعني اصابهم عمى ولا يرورون
التطبيق العملي لهذه الشعارات في الارض
الان يجري في الخرطوم وهنالك من يريد ان
يكافي
هذه المليشيا باعاده موضوعها في الجلسه
السوداني هذا هو ما هو مرفوض
رؤيتك
لرؤيه الدعم السريع في الواقع للخروج من
الازمه
يا استاذي الكريم الان الان الذين يتحدثون
الدعم السريع بالماليشيا الدعم السريع هو
مؤسسه يتبع يعني بقانون يتبع للقوات
المسلحه وقانون الجزر في المجلس الوطني
وليس الدعم السريع من ينهب ولا ولا من
يقتصد هذا كله كذب الضيفيك يكذبون على
الهواء مباشره الراي العام الرؤيه في الحل
ان يعترف الجميع ان هنالك ازمه ازمه ازمه
حكم متراكمه في السودان منذ الاستغلال حتى
الان
ماذا يعني فعليا ما هو الحل
كثير جدا من الاشكالات والعزمات نعم
الحل الاعتراض بهذه الازمه الحل الاحترام
بان هنالك ازمه حقيقيه يجب الجلوس يعني
لطاوله التفاوض ولا يعني وضع الرؤيه شامله
كما طرحتها الان قوات الدعم السريع لحل
جذور المشكله النظر لجذور المشكله منذ
الاستغلال حتى الان اذا لم ننظر الى جذور
يحدث بالعاطفه ونتحدث كل من ان يتكلم عن
الحق وينادي بالحق وينادي بالحريه
والعداله يوصف بالمتمر
كاملا هاتسن ماذا عن رؤيه الولايات
المتحده المنخرطه طبعا في مسار جده ما
امكانيه ان تستفيد من خروج البرهان الان
والدفع باتجاه انهاء الازمه بطريقه ما
جذور المشكله هي وجود ميليشيات في السودان
هذا هو جذر المشكله المشكله تحل حين يتم
التخلص من هذه المجموعات الميليشياويه من
اجل انجاح مسار جده
لابد من ان نجمع الجيش مع الاصوات الاصوات
المدنيين من اجل صياغه المسار المستقبلي
بعد خمس سنوات سيكون هناك جيش وطني سوداني
بدون وجود قوات دعم سريع يجب ان نقبل هذا
الواقع ونمضي قدما انطلاقا من هذه النقطه
من خلال ان نسمعها للجيش بان يتفاوض مع
المدنيين حول المستقبل ولكن لا يمكن لقوات
الدعم السريع ان يكون لها مكان في السودان
اشكرك دكتور كاملا
افريقيا في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
سابقا من ابوجا واشكر عبر الانترنت من
الخرطوم الباشات بيج عضو المجلس الاستشاري
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع ومن الدوحه عادل
الباز الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
واشكركم طبعا مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر في
[موسيقى]